will have Benjamin villalonga tell us
about the latest tensor Network
algorithms for simulating next
experiments
right thanks hello Bill and thanks
everybody for I'm here for inviting me
to give a talk so talking probably a
good Counterpoint to Verity article
computer science uh talks so this one is
very down to earth very
you know focused on on numerics and
evidence of whether these experiments
can be simulated or not and there is a
little bit of a discussion on whether
you know in the nisk era where errors
are not corrected and we're even
exponentially decaying uh signal every
time you run an experiment it is
possible to get an advantage before we
get low enough in our rates to to
implement QVC
so
given the recent paper from IBM this is
very much uh a good conversation to have
and we recently put on Google a paper
talking about about some of these
Concepts relating to the IBM experiment
but also do other experiments that we or
other groups have looked at in the past
okay so this work
by no means done exclusively by myself
this is work done with many
collaborators and in particular the
recent paper was written with all these
people that I acknowledged right there
but I'm going to talk about past
experiments also that I've worked with
on with with many people
so let me start by giving a very quick
summary of Where nice experiments are
right now
and sort of motivate the talk so many
groups
um particularly many industry groups are
focusing on scaling up error correcting
demonstrations and we've had some early
demonstrations already of some surface
code implementations some early error
suppression when scaling up the distance
of a surface code and also all the
flavors of error correcting
demonstrations from from many groups
also with the with this goal in mind in
the Horizon of implementing qec and
actually you know achieving the dream of
having actually fully fault tolerant on
computation and we are left today with
machines that are good enough to perform
substantially large computations in the
nisk era maybe with some error
mitigation or maybe completely
unprotected from noise
um some of them are motivated by physics
and they are trying to solve some some
useful problems
and from those there is a kind that
really just try to demonstrate
implementing some Physics on in
experiments and experiments happen to be
run on quantum computers but others
really make a genuine attempt to go
beyond classical and to and to run
something that is really hard to do with
classical means and then there's some
experiments on the on the Other Extreme
of not particularly looking for
application trying to demonstrate Beyond
classical computations but I repeat not
not with applications in mind although
they might derive into some applications
so that's unclear
and so I'm gonna focus on on this
experiment not on error correction
demonstrations and in particular I'll
focus on three works so one of them is
is a paper we put out a couple years ago
we attempted to have something
physically motivated talking about
information scrambling in in complex
Quantum systems but it fell short of
being non-simulatable by classical
computers
recently IBM put their their famous
paper on this local evolution of a
Transit field easy model which we're
gonna see is also falling short of that
goal and
and of course I'm going to talk about
run circuit sampling which is in a
different kind of class of experiment
which I would say to this day has shown
to be Beyond classical although you know
there's always a challenge to improve
classical methods
um I'm not gonna go into both on
sampling even though it has had a lot of
attention recently
um
is not part of the talk and also it kind
of it has a different flavor and
depending on what metric you you use to
define your Beyond classical goal
uh it might be simulatable in particular
Shanghai and I was going to talk on
Friday about his latest work and and
that one really suggests that these
experiments are are within reach
so let me start talking about a noise
and the effect of noise and why it
changes the game for nice experiments so
when you have noise in a Quantum
computation for a very simple minded
person
um you just think of the following so
every gate you apply with noise and in
particular noises
um
noise is is the main source of noise is
to give it Gates every time you play a
two cubic gate you are decreasing
exponential your fidelity
and eventually if you want to work with
a final Fidelity your your left with
only a final volume of volume of
computation that you can afford in your
computations
and so the nisk era is one that focuses
on finite sizes not on asymptotics
because they are really unreachable
and you can access
higher volumes but at very expensive
costs you would you have to either
decrease exponentially the error rates
of your components or you have to in
some cases if at all this is possible to
solve the problem you're trying to solve
uh you hit an exponential barrier in in
Sample complexity at the same time
classical methods also grow poorly with
volume size although I'm going to argue
later some exponentially
um and so there is this competition
between the two the two technologies
either very well developed classical
computers that suffer from you know
being
very bad similar in quantum physics or
quantum computers that are really bad at
scaling up the size of the computation
if errors are not corrected and so we're
left with these questions you know is it
possible in this era to have a
computation that is large enough that it
leads behind quantum computers I'm going
to argue that random secret sampling
shows that now is it possible to have a
computation that leaves behind quantum
computers but that is at the same time
useful or has some motivation
or motivates some group of people with
with some application in mind and and in
particular it's very important to ask
whether this is going to be possible
this is not going to be any room uh to
have this achieved before error rates
are low enough that we just go for the
cheaper route and just Implement our
correction
yes
exponentially decreasing your risk in
fact you only need three normally
go for the
okay
fair enough yeah yeah I'm talking about
worst case also here
one over n okay
then then basically
uh error is additive you get you can do
you can do Photon specification
yes yes I'm talking about nothing
at all
if you ever read this one over there and
probably
okay
this is if it's ideal because
let me very quickly just for one slide
talk about personal contraction as as a
very
very powerful tool for classical
simulation upon computations in
particular is not the only one
but but it's a large framework which
allows you to see
um computational costs from a very
different angles and which is going to
be a central part of our talk even
though I'm not going to go into into
large details
and so many computations in particular
Quantum computations Quantum circuits
can be mapped uh very easily onto tensor
networks how many operations can be
mapped onto tensors like Quantum Gates
uh State preparation
[Music]
um
pulse selection
projections noise channels Etc so it
really covers a large a large field of
of things we're interested in
and when you try to do this map you have
to write each component each gated each
noise Channel Etc as a tensor which is
each one of these boxes which has tensor
entries and which we're trying to sum
over and the order in which we take this
sum to compute what we want to compute
either an observable expectation value
uh probability amplitude etc for
whatever algorithm we want to run
classically depends dramatically on the
order in which we apply these sums
and so um
if we look at graph Theory
um there's a famous paper from from Igor
Marco and xiaozhen XI from 2008 where
they show that the cost of this tensor
contraction of the entire network grows
with some graph property called the tree
tensor Network the tree width of the
line graph of the network
and
it's actually more intuitive to think
about this complexity in terms of the
actual Network and it turns out with
some details on the uh very under the
rug that the complexity grows with some
area
um
so every time you are you are contracted
to tensors you build a new tensor that
is larger until you've contracted all
the tensors in the network the largest
tensor that you build along that path
is giving you the leading term in your
complexity and that's given by by the
area of the largest
tensor across this contraction so if you
optimize contraction paths you can see
that there is some lower bound to the
complexity that is given by by some
effective area of your of your some some
cross section of your tensor Network
so this is going to be an important
Concept in the rest of the talk and just
to give you some flavor of white and
Center works are important well there
are Primitives for many simulation
techniques classical techniques uh many
of them even though they are not
explicitly tensor networks they can be
mapped onto tensor networks maybe some
approximate contractions are in need
maybe some exact contractions it can be
regarded as some highly optimized Brute
Force approach to simulation
um and it's really in practice as a
classical competitor to random circuit
sampling experiments tensor networks was
the exact contraction of tensor networks
have has proven to be the leading uh
simulation technique at least for the
current noise
um noise rates
and in the to to build some intuition
um in the large depth limit of circuits
for finite sizes
the most efficient internal contraction
is really really similar to uh just a
wave function Evolution so once we are
in large steps it doesn't pay off to
optimize a tensor contraction we can
just if we can afford it we just do a
time evolution of the entire wave
function and this is as good as As It
Gets if we want to go with the right of
tensor contraction
so so let's see where tensor contraction
fits in random separate sampling so just
to recover quickly run secret sampling
we are sampling bit strings from a
random secret implemented on a quantum
computer
and then we have a in our case a tensor
Network sampler a fully classical
sampler is trying to compete with this
so it's gonna generate a bunch of bit
strings claiming that they are sampled
from this same distribution
and then the goal is to achieve a cross
entropy benchmarking Fidelity that is
larger than zero with some statistical
significance
okay so our latest results
um from a paper we put out a few months
ago uh show that with the best
techniques that we have which are
improved upon many works on
many works on on this contraction
optimization
um suggests that if we run the
computations on the largest
supercomputer in the world
which is the frontier supercomputer
right now but they keep improving and
making larger ones it would take a few
years about 50 years to simulate the
same computation
the the techniques have improved so much
that now if someone has the time and the
energy to implement this on Frontier for
example they would take just a few
seconds to simulate the experiment we
run in 2019
and in just a few minutes or a few days
for the usdc experiments which improved
upon that one
okay so
as a proxy to to contraction complexity
is not really sampling But A Primitive
sampling which is Computing a
probability amplitude of the circuits
um
one can
optimize sensor contraction and see how
costly would be to compute a single
perfect
um probability amplitude for a
particular between over these circuits
on a regime where we can either increase
the number of qubits on the x-axis or
increase the depth of these circuits
this is for an ensemble of circuits very
similar to the ones we run an experiment
and what one sees is that these two
regimes here one at high depth
in which the complexity grows
exponentially in the number of qubits if
we are always above a critical
depth in the circuit and at Short depth
the complexity grows with the effective
area which is now the depth times only
one of the of the spatial dimensions of
the circuit I'm assuming here as in the
four experiments that have been
published so far that we run this on a
on a grid that is two-dimensional I
guess we're talking about
three-dimensional tensor network two
dimensions are spatial and one is is
fine or that
yes
[Music]
so this crossover area or this crossover
line
drops on the square root of the of the
number of periods so so if it's super
linear you're expected to to be
a high battery
so it's still an explanation
yeah if you're it's a crossover region
so some moving planet sizes you you
don't see exactly that scaling but once
you're deep enough into this regime yes
into account in the simulation all right
yes so this plot is not showing any
noise this is
um how do we take the noise into account
in this simulation
in this simulation we're taking it well
not in particular these plots I'm
showing the computational cost to
compute a single perfectly perfect
amplitude but if you want to sample with
you know with to have a fair comparison
with experiment that have
um actually you can locate samples
on the way we're implementing noise is
by summing what the tensor contraction
is a large sum over many indices
only partially over these variables
turns out for scrambled enough systems
it gives you a Fidelity in the output
distribution which is linear in the in
the fraction of of paths to do something
yeah so we just get a little linear uh
time saving
how we do it this way
we're not implementing noise channels or
anything like that for this
trying to decrease the Fidelity yeah
without any physical uh noise Channel
um
yeah yeah the the way in which they
optimize is different from what we do
um you know different heuristics but the
framework is exactly the same and the
savings
so so much of the progress in classical
numerics have been coming from better
optimizers to to very simple ideas on
tensor Network interactions
so
so financing optimized further than
people have done before and also realize
that okay if you are going to compute
many
um amplitudes for sampling that are not
correlated that really
there's many ways in which you can do
reuse tensors and there is
um it's a lot of saving the time to the
solution is not linear in the number of
samples but they also had some way of
considering a non-ideal offensive
Network version uh yes yeah yeah that's
very similar to what we have in 2019 so
and that comes from the particular views
it's uh it's close to a nice one
so you can decompose it as a classical
swap with a control face
and uh gives you a tensor with only two
variables and not and not four
similar to when you implement diagonal
Gates like Ctrl Z you also have two
variables per degree not four variables
so it simplifies the network quite a bit
so okay so in the case of random circuit
sampling uh it seems like the signal
we're trying to measure across entrop
image marking really depends on the
entire volume of the computation any
error anywhere in the circuit is going
to kill your signal and bring your
Fidelity to to zero this makes the
experiment very sensitive to noise but
this makes also a classical simulation
very expensive very
hard to to get to to better scaling than
just worst case you know grow your
computational costs with uh with um
with a tree width of of the line graph
of the tensor Network at least for these
noise levels there's other works for
for a higher noise
um or other regimes so let me uh now
that we talked a little bit about volume
and how this computation really depends
on the entire volume of the of the
quantum circuit
let me introduce some ideas that we put
out recently on effective Quantum volume
of computations
so
okay so in a generic random circuit
every time you measure an observable and
your Fidelity is lower than one you're
gonna see a decrease in your signal that
for which the leading term uh is just
linear in the in the Fidelity and the
Fidelity as we mentioned earlier is
going to decrease exponentially in the
number of cases that are contributing to
this Observer which is uh basically the
volume of your computation
if we want to have a statistical
significance in your signal so we want
to have the optional we measure above
some some threshold above zero
uh this is going to put an effective cap
or affecting maximum in the volume of
computation we can afford with a
particular error rate per to give a gate
a dominant error rate
so this brings us to the discussion of
whether
the light cone of an observable in a
computation is really
the
the entire volume we have to take into
account or is just an upper bound and we
can do better in terms of uh seeing what
gates are really contributing to our
signal
and so many times in physics and
motivate experiments you see that the
um operator spread across many cycles
over on a computation or what is called
the butterfly velocity of your
information and grows slower than purely
the purely geometrical light cone and so
you see that only a fraction of gates is
are really contributing to to the
obstacle you're measuring
so in this case you can define an
effective Fidelity which is basically
relating
the observable you're measuring or the
signal you're measuring to be ideal one
and this is in turn a good proxy to the
number of gates that are contributing to
Europe several
so the effective Fidelity is giving you
a hint of well volume of computation
you're really using in in or you're
really seeing in the signal you're
measuring and this tells you effectively
once you know the dominant error rate
about how many gates are really
contributing
and so let's see how that relates to all
our experiments so I'm going to talk
about two experiments that I mentioned
already so information scrambling in
complex Quantum circuits from a couple
years ago and later in in about 10
minutes I'm gonna talk about the the IBM
experiment
yes when you talk about a butterfly cone
to have in mind
circuits
because otherwise in the worst case
of several dependent
um
I'm gonna show some examples of how
changing the Ensemble of circus or
something from really changes
yeah so it's very sensitive to one
Ensemble set which you're using okay
thanks
awesome yeah you're making
essential White Noise yeah
this is not generic but it's it's
typically what we see any particular
paper they made sure uh the noise was
was you know applying and squirting and
underneath sorry in the ideal experiment
they made sure that the you know they
use this zero nice extrapolation I'll
show in a second
that they
they basically tune their tournament to
have a particular
notes they apply it um
Okay so
um
experiments where we're approaching
probing the spread of information on the
quantum system with Autos or out of time
motor correlators
um and this is this comes into this
conversation from two sides
um in the first
um
one one angle that it comes in is from
the the fact that this experiment is
really trying to have a
um a computation that is beyond what we
can do classically but also it's going
to be very illustrative of how this
butterfly velocity uh comes into play
so when you have a
um
in this competition what we're trying to
measure is the spread of an observable
as we apply a unitary Quantum zipper on
top of it and there is this nice
quantity called the autok which is
basically measuring how two observables
or two operators at different times
commute with each other after they've
gone through
um uh unitary Quantum circuit the all
talk one does a little bit of math can
also be written as this four point
correlator
and in particular when implemented an
experiment it is equivalent to this
computation where
we have we initialize the system
apply a circuit and then before we
reverse the circuit and try to just
completely reverse the computation we
apply some perturation of some butterfly
operator in one of the qubits
and so you can see that this operator is
the identity then you have no effect
whatsoever everything commutes and you
get a a notebook of one
if this butterfly
um reaches if it spreads and reaches the
keyword we're measuring then you're
gonna see an auto that is a star
decaying
and
um as U is increased in in depth the
effect of the of the butterfly operator
o is going to spread to larger and
larger uh lengths and it's going to have
an effect on on a wider Support over the
circuit
um
which is basically the reach of this
butterfly cone
so this is experimental data after
applying some some noise mitigation
techniques I'm not gonna discuss
and in this case
you see that the the upper panels which
are implemented which are coming from
circuit sample samples with I swap to
giving Gates and random 1kb Gates
the effect of the of the butterfly how
it spreads after a certain number of
Cycles is really saturating the the
light code okay so the butterfly cone in
this case is is equal in size to the
light bone with different Gates say in
this case we have a square root of I
swap
um you see very clearly that the
butterfly velocity is smaller than than
the lycon velocity
and so really the effect some
preparation that you have on some qubit
at some point in your computation
reaches a distant qubit only after a
longer time it's not gonna spread
this perturbation as fast as the light
cone
and this has implications in both the
noise resilience of the experiments
which only effectively see a few fewer
uh Gates that you would expect from the
light bone
but also it has implications in the
classical computational cost of
simulating these experiments
and so even though this experiment in
particular had potential for Beyond
classical
physically motivated applications and
it's well beyond Brute Force approaches
it's it's a circuit run over 53 qubits
and larger depths than the 2019 random
circuit sampling experiment so it's
really really challenging to to simulate
in principle in practice
it turns out that the butterfly velocity
being smaller than the
um
and the light cone velocity uh lets you
play classical tricks on your tensioner
contractions
and in particular you can explain this
in many ways uh two simple ways all
right by just ignoring an environment
that is far enough from the observable
you're you're measuring a finite depth
or also variables in the tensor Network
that are far enough you can project to
some random value and you will see
basically only an exponential
um difference in the signal you're
measuring
if I become more radical I say that's an
intestinal type step but obviously I
will not spread by one side per step
right because yeah so in some sense if
I'm doing something with the comparison
like that I should be scared my time
steps as well right because if I'm doing
a square root of the operation I will
spread half as fast right sure sure I
mean I'm wondering how much of that is
due to that the fact that the gate is
not fully entangling and how much is
some different effect
okay yeah yeah
sure sure well in this case when you say
make sense is not 100 true because you
still have to one cubic gets in between
these two layers
if you take this little bit of taking
higher and higher roots of any gate yeah
obviously you will not reach the full
light corn right because somebody ever
continues
yes
and how much is due to that that the
Gates become less and less entangling
maybe so they spread information and how
much is
um
so yeah definitely gates are less
entangling uh spreadless information and
become easier massively let's say you
know control deviate is much easier
classic that's only a straight rank of
Two and a four
and still gains that have screen records
of four like in this case
uh
yeah depending on somebody or something
from you're gonna get different
velocities right
um
at least
I'm not sure if that has a simple
relation to locate that to the
entanglement
foreign
[Music]
experiments
hence the
um so the the theater the average case
is very easy to grasp in terms of being
efficiently and computed but then the
Beyond classical computation comes in
when you try to resolve every random
secret instance
and so let me go into
the other paper I'm going to talk about
which is the IBM
Berkeley experiment on the fluke
evolution of all the transfers field DC
model
and in this case we we have a different
flavor of experiment we're trying to
inspire by it by a particular
two-dimensional local hamiltonian which
is this easy model
um trying to evolve an initial state
and we're going to have some flock
Evolutions so the angles that we are
evolving with our finite there are no
infinitesimal Evolutions under after
some tradition
and the layout of the of the chip looks
like this it's two-dimensional but it it
is fairly sparse but it is nonetheless
two-dimensional
and after a few steps of the computation
where each step involves a one cubic
gates for the X rotations and then three
layers of ZZ rotations for to give with
degree Gates three layers because you
know because of constraints of the
hardware they have to be split in in
many levels instead of just collapsing
all to one but morally speaking it's
just one layer of one cubic Gates and
one layer of two Cubit couplers
um that forms a step and after a few
steps we might ask the question okay
um how much is the expectation value of
a particular local or slightly non-local
observable
and
um just to mention this experiment is
very nice in demonstrating a zero noise
extrapolation as a means to to apply
some error mitigation technique and it
lets them
measure a very clean signal of their
Observer
and so let's talk first about one of the
examples they they show which is in
principle very challenging classically
which is after 20 steps of computation
measuring Z
um Z operator on a particular qubit in
this case on the qubit 62 which is right
there in the middle
and then the the experimental data is
very clear so after the Nom mitigated
signal is is
you know it's all short in in the in the
case where the angle is zero and it
should be one it's about half of what it
is but after error mitigation we get a
fairly clean curve and when the authors
try to simulate this with classical
means in particular the light bone of
this experiment uh grows to the entire
chip so it's impossible to run away
function Evolution or or really any
other tensional contraction exactly on
the full support
and what they try to do is to run an
approximate wavefunction Evolution
through some classical methods in
particular two of them so the first one
is a matrix Arc State Evolution where
where the two-dimensional system is
snaked around with a one-dimensional
landsat and which has a problem of
building longer range correlations but
it's always a good thing to try and the
other one is uh By Nature a
two-dimensional landsats
which
um which is nonetheless very very
constrained and they fail at reproducing
the experimental curve
and so this suggests that the experience
is is hard to simulate
but when one looks closer to this and
and looks at the mitigated signal versus
the amitigated signal
it turns out that the effective Fidelity
of this
um of this experiment is really much
higher than what you would expect if all
the gates in the light cone contributed
to the signal
and so this suggests that the number of
gates that are contributing to this to
this observable is very low compared to
to the litecon count
so which is about 100 Gates instead of
almost 300 3000 Gates and so this
suggests that a small region of the
system will be enough to get a pretty
good signal of the observable
and so our idea was to simulate
um
this time Evolution only over a small
support of the system in particular when
you look at this observable on qubit
number 62. you just take the three loops
around it
isolate them and throw away every gate
that touches and queue it outside of
this region
um and then do a little bit of
convergence analysis taking fewer qubits
or taking more qubits it turns out that
at 28 cubits which is this this layout
that I'm plotting here
the signal is pretty much converged and
it's very much on par within error bars
or or even better convergence than the
experiment
and in this case it takes one second per
per data point reproduced from the
experiment uh on a single dpu
and so you might have to ask the
question well I talked quite a bit about
tensor networks why do we just run a
Time evolution of the entire wave
function and on a fully optimized
Samsung or contraction well this is a
really high depth redeem that we're
working with so so that doesn't buy you
much and pretty much the best you can do
is a full time evolution
and so the authors of the experimental
paper put out last week a second paper
explaining some numerical techniques to
also reproduce these results and or to
approximately replace the results and to
analyze a little bit more the physics
and they do confirm the from a auto
analysis similar to the one we saw
earlier that the spread of the operator
after a few levels of the of the circuit
is really slow
the qubits with an X are within the
light cone but but you can see that most
of them are really uncorrelated to the
to the central Observer
and so when you look at other examples
that they run in the experiment which
are
um where they are measuring non-local
observables so polish strings over
several qubits
um but now instead of 20 steps on the
computation they only run five steps and
that gives you a big enough light on
that you cannot attempt again to
contract exactly with tensor Networks
well it turns on that the same strategy
of just having a very small support of
qubits around the Observer that you're
measuring and you're simulating over
that support gives you a very clean uh
signal that basically matches many other
methods too
um okay so in this case the nautical
obstacle case yes
actually ideal yes Behavior
here uh the behavior that you're
assuming is true which is the Indian
Behavior plus uh plus the White Noise
right right so so um
are they basically
the same the the mini water testing for
convergence because regardless of the
experiment yes with the ideal case
not just not with their new case but
what you're trying to actually simulate
this ideal case plus uh White Noise
right no we're just simulating IBO oh
yeah
okay so yeah is this safe here yes well
converge out to the sizes that we looked
at yeah which it seems to be very
convergible yeah and it matches all the
techniques because there was some
remarks about 20 percent difference
um so in this case
in the previous case
there is a there seems to be pretty much
convergence but there is still a slight
discrepancy between 28 and 31 cubits
so there might be still a little bit you
can you can buy
um I would say it's less than 20 but but
they still
I would say that converts but you know
to one decimal but
yeah and and
in the in this case they are pretty much
converged like when you increase the
number of qubits it's just you you come
up with the same curve that's nothing
changes if your control parameter is is
what size of support you're simulate
so okay so in this case with another
local observable
um what is happening one would expect
um
not only the icon but also the butterfly
cone to spread quite a bit
but it seems to be nonetheless simple
and even simpler than than the local
Observer will simulate and and so what
might be happening is the following so
the Outsource of this experiment in
order to have some signal over these
fairly non-local observable uh they made
sure that when the angle of the X
rotations is a pi over two which is a
which
it gives you a Clifford circuit they
made sure that the Heisenberg Evolution
or the observable they are measuring
okay so there's an evolution backwards
it's a from from the highest level of
the circuit all the way to the beginning
um as they apply uh you know Opera
Evolution The Observer ends up
collapsing to just one single site and
so by definition you're gonna find
uh uh
an expectation value of one in that
point
and so now when you continuously tune
away from that point you're gonna see
that that curve goes down until it just
connects it to zero
and so this computation has a some sort
of inverted light bone
where of the the full observable instead
of broadening its support is really
shrinking it by definition
and what happens when you pert up around
that point
is that numerics seem to suggest that a
small
dressing of this observable around the
Clifford path is good enough to give you
a very strong signal
and so
we didn't include this in our paper but
other two papers including the IBM home
response and Garnet chance paper from
Caltech uh they both take advantage of
this by having a Heisenberg evolution of
the operator which is truncated in in
two different ways
um and that seems to be enough to get a
very good signal and so obviously I have
to talk about the all the three papers
are also attempted and pretty much
succeeded on simulating this experiment
so one of them attempts also full wave
function evolution of the system but in
such a way that you know with a
two-dimensional landsat that is somewhat
more frugal than the one the original
Outsource used
it relies on some assumptions so it
works well for these kind of layout
where there's a lot of sparsity and the
contraction that they have to take in
the numerical procedure
are not in general efficient on a 2d
lattice but they're approximating the
lattice by by some small tree and that
is that gives them a good approximation
in in this case of having a sparse to
the lattice
um now this this introduces some
uncontrolled approximation and and in
terms of that in some curves uh they
they don't converge to the right point
but but they are within a reverse for
the experiment
um
also you might ask okay the whole
conversation here is about operator
spreading but these people are not
looking uh are not exploiting that at
all they are taking the entire full wave
function the entire wave function and
relying on it having small entanglement
since this kind of onsets is good in
that in that regime uh well it turns out
that also a small butterfly velocity
um gives you a small spread of
entanglement and then entanglement
builds up much slower than that you
would expect from uh from uh from a
generic case
or uh put out a paper where they do
attempt to do a Heisenberg Evolution the
exact one is not possible but they do
this in um over a truncated basis of
public strings and that seems to work
fairly well it the numerates are not
fully converged but they're in the right
direction and they're also within error
bars from the experiment
and and the IBM response to their own
paper also attempts something similar
not on a truncated basis of public
strings but on a truncated mpo that
encodes the operator as it Heisenberg
evolves with a final Bond Dimension and
that again seems to
be in the going in the right direction
not fully converged in all cases but but
pretty much suggesting similar ability
of the experiment and having better
errors than a comparable to the
experiment
and so let me finish by
talking about the relation between the
classical and computational cost and the
quantum computational cost
once um we take into account this notion
of a of an effective volume of the
computation
so the effective volume that we find
within uh the butterfly cone uh stemming
from an operator
um
is gonna basically tell you how much of
a signal you can expect in your
computation and that's gonna that's
gonna give you a maximum volume that you
can that you can afford
so in the classical case the contraction
cost of attention Network grows not with
the volume on the computation but with
this effective area of the computation
and I'm putting again some details under
the rug like having access to to high
memory systems once we have to
once we have to play tricks to to to
work with actual computers that don't
have anything in memory we have to to
take some overheads but in principle the
complexity grows in this way and so we
see a different scaling in both in both
cases the
the volume that we have access to
experimentally
which you know is is
um capped by this financial uh
suppression of fidelity with with error
rates
with a number of gates
um is only going to give a sub
exponential scaling for the contraction
cost
um in the volume
and so without error correction where
this is the game
um we just have to focus on finite sizes
and there is a lot of factors to think
into account Beyond these syntax and I
promised this talk was not about
asymptotics but finite volumes and
that's and that's true and well there is
different prefactors to both
um to both players uh there is a
different prefector to the exponent as I
said final memory systems might give you
a pretty big hit on classical computers
[Music]
um
and and also there is the the potential
to to to improve on this experiment
experiments and decrease error rates
still before fault tolerance
if you don't measure if you measure more
than observable if you measure
correlations it's really different parts
of the system then sure then and then
yeah and you're gonna be
computation
your message here is that classical
simulations are going to be uh Quantum
in this era if I don't know many
assumptions with many assumptions but
but uh but I'm just saying that this
argument works for local observables and
if you want to generate for example
Zeppelin
okay
if you want to sample
um I don't know the entire system then
then that's no longer true because the
correlations are not generated by
by the the light points
it's basically I mean this argument
basically goes back to the argument that
low deaths
um and low depths uh Quantum circuits
you can generate classically by just
Computing finite size life
the outcome of a local observable but
you cannot predict the outcome of of
samples out of the slow depth circuit
because sure correlations so it's the
same same problem here okay yes yeah
yeah well
because I'm nice yes but not just
because of the so they're completely of
correlated if you take a cubit in the
upper left hand corner right of the
diagram
yeah yeah pretty much during the
evolution yeah
yeah so okay but still that's kind of
not good right if you want to claim you
have a quad resist
it's not what you were saying no I'm
just saying uh the message of this slide
does not apply for the case for example
or for the case of non-local heavyweight
observables
not directly so
even with sampling on low that final
circuits
you can
if the person argument is is slow or if
it's really hindered by noise
you can also
try to use you know some some low
entanglement answers
something like that and still has a full
way function on Sample yeah
but the light cone argument I don't know
right right yeah yeah
which is related to the
to the same question of spiritual
entanglement but it's not directly
is
um basically the width when you
so this cone has a lot of gates in it so
basically I have a tensor Network within
it that you need to contract
and the best contraction you can take
is its cost is a lower bounded by new by
the
as you take all the possible
contractions that you can take
contraction paths each one of them has a
maximum width at some point
and when you from all the possible
contraction paths you can take can be
lower when you try to find a minimum of
those
maximum widths of each contraction
that's basically your logo and that's
your effective area of the contraction
yeah to what extent are you exploiting
the architecture and to what extent that
is providing the circuit like could I
just go and run you know you showed at
the beginning your slides from your
other place iPhone
could I just go run a different model on
the IBM processor and your simulation
method will be doomed or is it if you
manage to spread the operator fast
enough yes but then the experiment will
suffer from from
Port signal
I think they are probing larger portions
of the chip so in other words this
experiment yeah
DNA with what they're using right
yeah you need you need a high enough
um
noise ratio
even to use aromatication
maybe maybe I'll make my question
sharper suppose IBM
made a difference would have measured a
different observable
which is uh basically measuring the
entire the entire system all the qubits
together in some I don't know
um then would your simulation work
no it would not work but also the
experiment would likely not work Network
um at high enough steps it will not work
we will have to see if I know that we
can have some nice long time and answers
that works but that as a generic
question of you know if you're measuring
a number called completely normal
observable and just how attention
contract it
foreign
this doesn't rule out all their methods
can you make a general statement in
terms of
how scrambling the circuits can be for
this the noise mitigation method to work
as opposed to your kind of cloud
consideration
can you repeat it so
there seems to be a trade-off right if I
scramble more there's more scrambling
then I get a lower Sigma yeah so error
mitigation becomes much happening yes
yeah that's problematic for your
simulation method on the other hand if
you scramble the signal is higher but
then your simulation
correct correct so then
well
that's that's the whole point like
we want to have a Beyond classical
case
uh where where they have already crossed
and you know you can't measure a signal
on your device and you cannot do
anything with your arm do you think they
went to the limit of what the error
mitigation can do
but this is what you're just saying that
the signal
you change the operator then the signal
would would be worse yeah you don't know
that right it's not you you think that
this is what will happen yeah supported
by numerous experiments
uh sorry maybe maybe I missed that so so
you you do have evidence that when you
have when you have a stronger more
entangling
um than more entangling operators that
you would signal okay
I didn't see that so wearing them
well the um okay understand that the
lights will grow much more sure but then
why in this case the the
so the suggestion that we could simulate
this we just assuming a very small
support of the of the circuit
came from looking at uh how bad the
signal was
the ideal signal
so so the this factor in between the
mitigator and the mitigated signal
third in the world space to suggested
that the the support that we have to
simulate is about 100 days and that
seems to be true after running errors
okay
and so
answer the questions are the same at
least from this one framework that you
know
brings light to some some particular
angle of this of these experiments
fun but there's of course many other
discussions to have
um but other computations that are
already in this regime or classical
methods scale poorly but also quantum
computers have a hard time scaling up
um are the computations that are already
Beyond classical
would argue random secret sampling for
the moment is but you know people like
the challenge to take it down so so
that's always under consideration and
and are there useful computations or at
least computations that have more of a
physical flavor
um
potentially and hopefully but then you
know not yet not none other papers have
been published yet uh seem to bring this
to the table
um so let me acknowledge a bunch of
people I've worked with so in theory
yeah
a big part of Theory comes from from
surgeon and costly
um large number of numerics over these
years have been run by by Sergey and
Salvatore and also have a lot of close
collaborators and I talk regularly and
sort of inspired this talk uh Bill and
jenken and worked out with a lot of
quantum Google Quantum collaborators in
in all of these experimental papers and
here's the bibliography of the papers I
I talked about in more depths
[Applause]
yeah
but what do you mean by the single song
for butterfly velocity it's necessarily
defined in the limits of asymptotically
long times in space in which case
biography it should equal but yeah
so I can understand all this thing
single sample budget by velocity
so in the case of Autos you you can
measure uh you know out of time order
correlator between two seconds
limit sure in which case by electricity
recover the average case is the fair
enough yeah these are all the final size
statements yeah so then what you
actually
measuring when you say BB Okay so
I know fair enough at no point we
actually try to to say the velocity is
so much so many so many sites for per
per level but you can make a precise
statement of what the author is between
two observables at our particular time
of particular length apartment
sizes of course
please clarify the stimulation
meaning uh the factory donations agree
with the experiments is one thing but
you're making some approximations in the
simulation
and how do you verify is there is there
any proof that this actually works
basically it converts within its own the
verification
without the verification
simulations
are correct yes basically basically by
the experiment or by they agree with
each other is yeah
they agree with each other they bring
their self-consistent with themselves
after increasing
in in our case the number of Cubes that
we're simulating in all the cases the
one dimension of the MTO the size of the
of the basis of other operators that
you're using Etc so it's each one has
its own set of parameters and when you
scale them up they seem we converted
chocolate and do you adapt the
simulation
so is it the one-size-fit-all simulation
or do you actually change it for for
every system that you're simulating yeah
in principle is different production
from the point of view that you're
basically
uh you basically can learn it to every
system so
um
would expect if you if you wanted to
trust
such a tool that it would that it would
work with before with without
fine-tuning it to every to every system
well again High disagree because the
experimental parameter is also different
that's what the systems are different no
of course it should it should not be
modified by the parameter
um but as as a tool
you're saying that it only depends on
the parameters but the tool itself is
fixed yes yeah you have another respects
whether you know they have a family of
methods with maybe related by some
parameters depending on the methods what
dimension or basis size
um or support size
but the method
model of that parameter is fixed
anyone else
[Applause]